hello and welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 it's Michael
it's Tam again and I'm so excited for
this segment because we're talking about
Nashville chain one of the games always
looking forward to to seeing because
we're talking anime talking to animate
Cobbs are talking that's Beca anime all
in stylish action this is the next game
coming out of a taki cetera who worked
on Nier automata so this is he's leading
up this projects and out he's into the
full control of what he's creating and
I'm liking what I'm seeing so but for
those who are not aware of what astral
train is can you lay the groundwork for
them sure
so I'll say it this way it's really
about synergetic action and the two kind
of key words for it you know really it's
about knowing how your abilities can
start kind of you know you kind of
attack character since I thought you
tagged enemies but you also think have a
legion a Legion is kind of your there's
different legions they're kind of
attached to you through that chain right
so as you can see here behind us you see
how you're actually cop yes you talk
about things like that yes you're a cop
and you're in this in this world in
which the astral plane exists and
through these astral planes this these
enemies come called chimera out of it
and also through the astral plane also
dimension you have your let's call you
have your Legion and what's interesting
about this it's not just like all action
it's actually mixed right so there's
this really fast action traditional
platinum like all for twitch I'll go
into that a bit later and right now it's
also investigation so what he what
Demetrius is did he's the guy that's
playing back there Demetrius went ahead
and hacked into that camera and what
he's looking at is looking at a replate
he's trying to track down the woman
named Jenna and that's the replaying
gold of where she was at a little bit
ago so he's kind of questioning a few
people and you probably also see him you
know try and be good cop and that's at
him just taking out his baton just just
because guys no it's fine it's fine
thank you so again you can call upon
your you know your gosh why am i
blanking out here CL I just know that by
a button
what's a call get you call upon your you
know your helper yeah see now I'm just
blanking it's all good man is it again
right Legion see I was like L Louise
so you call upon your Legion right you
combine you can do things now right now
again there's a main story mode so in
the main tour there's a main objective
so the main objective says you know
guide the last man what you're really
doing this are still looking for Jenna
but along the way your main objective
you can also have to you know you can be
society event side quests and one of
them is like questioning these people so
it's like oh yeah Jenna you know a
question locals have you seen this woman
oh no reason I'm not really asking
fanboy freaks out and let go there you
go run straight dirty rumors like it's
really nothing you have a
misunderstanding he gets a bit angry do
you back off a second oh wait a minute
so he whips up the Legion and beaten you
can actually bite and chain citizens
again super friendly right behind calm
down you good
[ __ ] sorry I got passion it's fine but
what you're gonna see is you'll start to
realize that you're not just control of
your character right the interplay
between your legion is how she's gonna
start popping up when we get into
gameplay like when we get into like
those battles but the leech is also very
useful in solving some of these side
quests such as a very angry upset fanboy
I'm thinking of like a lot of this calls
back to a lot of elements of like maybe
watch dogs or la noir but that this is
in a traditional open-world as well so
what are the things have you looked at
to kind of make sure that you're in tune
with like outside of combat that we're
doing things differently from others or
that we are combining the best elements
of game investigative games the way I'd
position it is it's not exactly open
it's a little bit open-world we're in a
like it's a harmony square it's one of
the locations that you can okay kind of
exciting problems right yeah it's kinda
like a hub a little bit but there are
different locations you can kind of jump
to but really it's mainly focused on yes
there's some elements of exploration and
finding clues and trying to track down
you know people but there's also really
getting into some pretty insane combat
sequences so I know to me just is like
totally jetting to the locate I could
feel it in this block I'm running so
fast and what's funny is while we're
running that way I also want to kind of
jump into if you're a Platinum Games fan
yes you'll have your planet being specs
believe me we'll get to that in a second
what you don't necessarily see and kind
of a new blood and the new producers and
developers in here a new idea so there's
a little bit this investigation you see
now there's also other elements like I
don't know if you saw that a while ago
but to me just walked over and picked up
a can in the top left hand corner
there's a little flower symbols of 3046
there is actually a way to be a good cop
and it pays off for you cuz you can
spend some of those points and actually
level up some abilities thank you for
look at that good way to be a model
shining example of the police force and
I'm alright anything that there's also a
mechanic where you can rescue cats
something is there a cat rescuing
mechanic that was rescuing yeah I would
more like an animal rescue because I
interviewed Thomas on yesterday and he
mentioned there's more that they're
gonna be talking about that allow people
to be kind of like the good cop in the
game yeah there are a variety of
different ways you can interact with
citizens and do the right thing so yes
example saving a cat may be one of them
same thing with picking up cans as
you're walking around right but right
now we're actually heading into the
astral plane right now the astral plane
is for all these you know where most of
your fights take place now in the astral
plane again the bad guys are called
chimeras they are they're just basically
enemies and the astral plane things are
warp you know there's a bunch of
basically bad guys coming out trying to
destroy the planet and there's a couple
of puzzle elements here so as you can
tell Demetrius had to shoot that little
cube lowers the wall and then he's able
to get through any right now this is
kind of an example of a little bit of
combat here it'll get pretty intense in
a second right and to go a little bit
more into the battle elements it's one
of my favorite things about the game I
remember picky enough at the first time
and in the bottom left-hand corner
you'll see that there's actually three
different weapons that your ex baton can
become one of them right now he's got a
small baton he could switch them to
either a sort epic gun right there and
guns for a long way to Texan that's his
sword swords great for breaking shields
and things like that
now as you start to attack a character
you or attack a second enemy you would
press either a weak kind of your purse I
guess a physical attack which is your CR
button and to Korea and for you to
actually summon your Legion to attack in
two presses the yell button whenever you
see a blue flash so that's like a
synergy attack right all right now
what's interesting is so you have three
weapons for your personal so he's right
now he's going
to him after this chimera with that with
his sword and he's changing off at the
right time to let his legion attack now
there's multiple legions so now let's
back that up a second you have multiple
weapons with all different combo types
you can tap you can hold to charge you
can tap that tap wait
delay tap it again it's a different move
it also happens for the legions leaders
coming at one time you can pocket the
leech and put them away and something
called a perfect calls or so if you
attack without your legion oh I bet you
need to try to do it right now you can
actually get one of your allegiance to
you know pop out and counter and really
destroy them you can even have two
legions out at one time you can call one
legion send them out do you like some
kind of special move so they're
constantly out doing damage then summon
your other legion to come in and do dual
attacks so there's an incredible amount
of depth to the level of battle that's
really I haven't seen before in a
platinum game and I started messing with
it and I just couldn't help myself I was
there for hours just messing with a
combo system but Lee Chi there's
multiple legions as a sword one there's
an arrow Legion then even when you have
let's say a soar legion your gun and
blade lose all that it'll be different
when you equip the arrow Legion so it
starts to get complicated pretty quick
but everyone's gonna have favorite
combos and styles I mean your stylish
action and combat you'll have it in
spades and you'll be even working on try
to bind enemies to figure out how to do
critical damage and pull them down
depending over the enemy patterns or it
gets pretty pretty deep and I'm sorry if
I'm talking way too much cuz I am super
excited this is really the first time
we've ever really shown it outside of
treehouse lives I can't let's so it's so
exciting it's all good man because yeah
there's there's so many layers here
because coming off of DMC 5 where
there's there were a lot of layers there
and especially switching between the
different characters there and like I
see a lot of that here also with with
the different legions with the different
weapons in a ways it's very overwhelming
but in a good way and I'm thinking about
what a Terrace on did with Nier automata
where you know you have different should
you have the chipset you have different
weapons if you have pods yeah and but it
was pretty East it was pretty easy to
get a grasp for that but going into a
chicane was he thinking about like no I
need to like take things for the next
how can I just like add even more layers
to that formula especially coming from
platinum with such a such a deep history
of doing that yeah I think it's a mix of
really surprising people you know we've
heard also the comment that they're also
trying new things so yes the depth is
one to get there now but could you also
pass the game we're just kind of
comboing around and just kind of going
you know you're 0zr then waiting for the
blue flash and then summoning your city
it's like yeah you could you have to
change so much you don't necessarily
have to change so much so really it's
like the classic Nintendo way of
thinking about a game right you want you
a little yeah little but if you really
want to to a lot you can even set a
skill to you know kind of a ridiculous
or not there's even like a skill tree
for you to unlock even more skills into
addition to your perfect calls your
counter your perfect dodge counters
there it's like there's even like a
flick up with your left stick towards an
enemy to actually do a raw counter so
there's there's tons and tons of death
for the people that want it so this is I
mean me being a big fan of you know
Platinum's games especially like you
know like Bayonetta of humanity not all
yeah and wonderful 101 even that was
when I game before - I can't help myself
and I freaked out when I was able to get
my hands on a michael mentioned that
earlier and the chips kind of approached
Phinney automata what's the progression
system like in a natural chain how does
a player grow and you mentioned it
earlier with the skill tree can you talk
a little bit more about how the
character growth and player growth
happens in the game yeah so there's two
primary ways right one is obviously to
gain experience right and you can spend
that experience to unlock different you
know different modules the basically
small modules that you can unlock to
unlock new moves or boost to your health
or boost a particular damage or
something right so there's that but also
I talked about the cop points earlier
and so of course picking up a can may
not seem pretty meaningless or not
jaywalking right serious I'm not I can't
make this stuff up guys not jaywalking
also is a good thing for you to help and
that will actually increase like your
health
right you can also customize you know
different skills skill moves because
there's also for each of the legions
there's some you hold down our button
you can either press Y or X a change up
what their skill is going to be so you
can really customize the kind of
No the kind of play you want not just in
just you know spend point it unlock
something but starting to learn the
details behind the strengths and
weaknesses of each of the legions as
well as the the weapon types for each of
the legions and really playing that into
the way that you want a place if you
want to be up in front I know that
there's a really big Liege it's got
these big like I've got ax and so you
can really slam axes in to people via
from but you have to make sure that
you're equipped and your skillset allows
for you to be a friend somebody's face
as opposed to something let's say an
arrow Legion which you want to be
farther away
maybe rely on the gun a bit more and
they kind of tailor your skillset to fit
that kind of game style so there's a lot
of ways to grow but it'll be gradual
believe me um you get taught little by
little yeah that's one of the
challenging things that this a stylish
action game is like how do you introduce
those layers how do you tutorial eyes oh
stuff and from what I'm seeing it like
do you it does tout us on or does anyone
like ever feel like we need to scale its
back it it might be too much how do i
mat all of these controls seamlessly to
a controller like is there ever like you
ever feel like there's feature creep so
what he just have too much like how do
you balance out though you know i will
say that it's always a struggle for
developers when they're figuring out
what what works right you don't throw in
features for just to have a feature
because another game had a feature right
once you start to learn the interplay
between you and you're leaching you
start to figure out what works for you
and it's important that you latch on of
that and they slowly introduce the fact
that okay here's your combo system let's
focus on that first to give you one
Legion then they'll give you another
Legion you focus a bit more on a
different combo set because they gave
number two different legions to your
combo sets then people to take a look at
to what the base are introducing your ex
baton and so they start be like yeah
it's a very gradual learning process I
mean even with any even Bayonetta for
example you know platinum has a really
great way of introducing those feats
where it doesn't seem overwhelming
because it really is a longer form game
and this is a bit later on in the game
too you're not just starting off all
this TBH trust is nice enough to bring a
save file from work actually and build
it up Thank You D and you know he really
he really did a number unlocked a bunch
of stuff for us so all the combos you
seeing all the all the bling all the
other legions and the weapons and what
he's doing here
and just getting rekt for a five-second
so I had to I had a roast in person that
was glad yet so I was like oh yeah he's
he's got a lot of work on this really
set it up for us and yeah we're showing
you a lot right now much of the stuff
that we're actually seeing on screen can
you talk through what Demetrius is
actually doing on a moment-to-moment to
kind of give us that platinum style of
game what at the moments way this is a
distinctly platinum thing like a which
time like you know shadow booths like
where is it here and so on I will say
that I think as far as his particular
action on-screen everything from the air
combos that he's doing the finishers all
that that's def of course trademark yeah
I know game right super flashy super
showy and let's just say that the more
that you start to figure out that
interplay between your Legion and your
attacks you're doing it to unlock more
waste like right now he's even like
change something which is super super
cool to do you can send ZL out to kind
of go after them and then change jump
directly to them to approach them in the
air at your body normally wouldn't be
able to do that if you didn't send your
Legion out first there's there's a lot
in there yeah yeah that's that's one of
the most exciting parts about stylish
action just like how how can i push the
limits of my capabilities like how can i
just string everything to have just one
seamless combo one after the other right
oh yeah we also got this we also got
rankings in here you can't have a
platinum game without getting writes
your material code that first time bonus
so that makyla code is the kind of a is
one of the currencies that you use to
upgrade your rhymes like the chip system
well I definitely can use that to
upgrade your abilities okay that's the
end of our case actually but okay yeah
you can definitely a lot more forward to
because Ashley train is you know it's on
its way very soon yeah I want to take a
step back and kind of talk about the
story elements a little bit more because
you know coming off of mere automata
obviously that was a Yoko taro join and
I guess made more or less the
expectations are a little high on the
story end I think that there there can
be a lot of like cool things that can be
told through a short chain with it being
about you know
and you know their role in the world so
can you speak to how you know the team
is approaching the story this time
around okay without giving any spoilers
I'll keep it really light all right
trailer we did see someone in a chair
giving orders someone I won't tell you
what that is and also everything is not
as it seems the astral plane is
something it just kind of happened a
rift opened up you know when all of
these enemies are flowing through it and
bad things are happening to the planet
and you're really there to kind of
protect what's going on you're the more
I think about it if I say anything yeah
I should have each other's like no
really it's super good and I will say
you will find twists and turns in the
story that you were not expecting so
I'll leave it at that all right please
something for people to look forward to
at least maybe expand on what you mean
when you talk about like being a good
cop like will your well your actions be
reflected in the story and will that
will you see that play out in different
ways yeah I won't say no looking back at
y'all it'll affect only strictly those
points that I was talking about before
how you can have those good cop points
that's really what it's about and I will
say that if you you know the more that
you go out of your way to be a good cop
the more that you'll find some of those
side side missions and side stories so
it really is to your benefit to try and
do the right thing because I'm sure
you'll find more nooks and crannies for
people that need help right and I'll
just give you more opportunities to
increase you know your abilities tonally
speaking what kind of what can people
expect in terms of tone because a lot of
the trailers that they've we've seen so
far are in classic anime fashion heavy
on the melodrama and heavy heavy on
characters being looking a bit upset but
you know PlatinumGames have this history
of being quite playful at times and
almost like humorous what kind of tone
are we gonna get out of actual chain
broadly speaking I think you'll get a
mix of a lot of things I mean even when
I was messing around in the there's like
a training ground that you can have like
inside your kind of your Basin in your
on base and I remember this being this
mascot right I know
everyone is uh everyone's really serious
and you're right you did see a little
bit of the serious town in there but I
remember going back and there's a smash
gecko and hey how can I help you and
it's nice I don't fits a bear oh yeah oh
just like but I mean that's the kind of
fun right there's a little bit of
silliness there is a little bit there's
a little bit of serious elements there
so it kind of a juxtaposition I think
it's about that I think it's about you
know no matter if you if you like funny
things or if you like things are
unexpected something will make you laugh
something will make you smile and
they've they've really gone the extra
length if they're the text of the
characters the diversity of who's
represented and also your customization
options I hope everyone will be very
very pleased yeah can you expand a
little bit on the character
customization because it's not just like
I'm playing something that's based
around a preset character can you walk
us through some of the options that you
have to create your own character for
Asheville Jane anime here
yes lots lots of cool hair in Demetrius
case he actually doesn't have hair he
shaved it he does but you just raise it
so his character looks like him in the
game me I look some kind of like
mismatch like nine year old oh it's
great it's so that I mean you do have a
lot of flexibility males females and you
also have a can I talk about the twin
I'm cool to say that oh great you also
have technically a twin so Asheville
chain you have your character you can be
boy girl whatever and then you have a
twin which I think is the opposite sex
no matter which you choose right and
then what's called depending on who you
pick you know you'll have of course your
counterpart and sure your twin comes
into play at some point later on it's
really really interesting yeah man I can
i I want to watch the actual training I
want to watch we'll play it even more I
want to keep asking questions I want to
see this in action I'm gonna get my
hands on it
fortunately I can't but yeah this we
have to wrap it up unfortunately and
yeah thank you so much desi for joining
us and walking us through ash machine I
think that there's there's something
special that can be done with the story
obviously the expectations are very high
but you know I feel like I believe in
Tower songs vision that he can uh you
know pull it off this time when he's a
you know at the helm of this project so
yeah I'm very excited for Astor chain
and I want everyone out there to stick
around though because we have so much
more to cover here on gamespot we have a
Blair Witch coming up so stay tuned for
that
[Music]
[Applause]